My first job was one when I was still a
college student.
Um,
I was an officer,
a young father the first time.
Um,
and I don't know if,
if my age contributed to my,
um,
a terror,
uh,
that's something might ever happen to
this child.
Um,
but having children in my life,
uh,
having them be such a presence in my
life for as long as they have been.
Um,
uh,
that boy was born when I was 22.
I'm 67 now and my 18 year old still
lives under my roof in,
in my house,
um,
for another year before he's off to
university.
Um,
and,
uh,
that's kind of a long time,
from the age of 22 to 67,
uh,
to have had one or more of my children
living at home with me for all those
years.
It certainly has informed what I write
about how childhood and adolescence,
uh,
are in 10 out of 12 of my novels.
Such,
um,
uh,
a vital part of the story.
Uh,
so I suppose it would surprise no one to
think that my principal anxieties,
um,
in my real life or parental,
their anxieties,
um,
for my children and by extension now for
my grandchildren and,
um,
and for my wife,
for it,
for everyone.
I love,
I,
um,
I'm a natural worrier.
It,
it's what I do for a living.
I create characters that I'm very fond
of and visited upon them.
The worst things I can imagine,
it's as you might well understand it,
it's,
it's hard not to do that when you leave
your office,
um,
you don't have the opportunity to stick
your imagination under your desk and say
hello to it again.
And the next morning it comes with you
write it,
it goes where you go.
Um,
so with three children and four
grandchildren,
I have a lot to worry about,
um,
before I turned my attention to the
state of the world.
But it's,
it's not that that leaves me an
entirely,
uh,
at ease either.